okay legend in the live it take the script and
rip it up with a touch I'm like Midas the odds
are against us but I'm like Leonas I'm going
to win I'm already the you can feel the energy
everybody's excited they can feel it the feeling
cannot be ignore I cannot be stopped I'm kicking
down the doors I'm about to do it like nobody
did it yo we coming through and you know we
mean business come and join the winning team you
know you want to be with us we be shining lot of
stars l a big di yeah you know we go hard
we the big hitters big big H you don't want
to miss this hey hey big big hit you don't want
to miss this big big hit you don't want to miss
this heyy big big hit you don't want to miss
this I'm not from this world still a visitor
haters get if I start they miss yo it's game
time it's unmissable I told them I will blow up
couldn't convince enough but look at me now Look
at what happens when you face The Impossible and
juny going like whatever I'm invisble no one
said it would be easy it was difficult but I
can't push it on I st original know we coming
through and you know we mean business come and
join the winning team you know you want to
be with us we be shining lot of stars lot
of big dier yeah you know we go hard we the big
hitters let's get it big big hit you don't want
to miss it let's get it let get it big big hit
you don't want to miss this last one was fire
pleas let them know there see nothing yet I keep
bring more let's get it B Big H you don't want
to miss this yo we coming through and you know
we mean business come and join the winning team
you know you want to be with us we be shining
lot of stars lot of big yeah you know we go
hard we the big hits get it big big H you don't
want to miss this don't want to miss big big h